you've been married for how many years
41.
41 years but who's counting 41. 41 years
uh
and you've told me many times that the
secret to your marriage
is that you work a lot and you go on the
road
yeah and that made me curious
you've been in quarantine with your wife
for a year
how's the marriage doing well
like the pandemic you know there's uh
we're trying to plat
the thing is that um that's what did
make it work i i realized
you know and now with uh you know the
advent of
uh you know no audiences and no theaters
i'm going crazy being with myself so i
can't imagine what it's like living with
i don't have to imagine she tells me
what it's like living with me um we had
and
in the first three months of
lockdown i think about march april may
in may
um uh what was march i can't remember we
celebrated our 40th anniversary
and uh i said honey i was trying to be
romantic i said you want to redo our
vows hers
was enough already um that's her
that's her that's her 40-year vow is
enough already
what a sweet vow well she's always been
honesty is her policy
and uh the truth is when i'm not around
people seem to like me
more than you know it's nice if i appear
on your show for a few minutes or i go
to a concert for an hour and a half
people seem to have fun living with me
isn't i
i i'm telling you this living with me is
no fun i spend
all day just trying to get away from me
yeah so
i can't imagine how another human being
so i'm hoping at
some point when things are open and free
that i could
uh get her a medal or a trophy
she is the most deserving person in
humanity just
for putting up with a world pandemic and
howie mandel
all in the same year at the same time
and even when i do try
humor she'll go was that joke you know
or who was that for
and and that's actually you know how the
podcast came to be
i ended up calling my daughter uh
jacqueline schultz who was an influencer
in her own right
really smart a teacher we used to sit
around for hours and that was my
if i could make her her and i would
laugh we'd make prank calls together
my wife would walk in and she'd hear all
this laughter and goes what is this for
and i go what do you mean what is this
for she goes well is it for a television
show
what do you read and i go no it's just
us she goes well then record it
um what's nice about i would think about
the podcast
is that you're doing something
uh useful with something that you'd be
doing anyway
it sounds to me like your whole life i
mean i've been around you
the times you've done my show you're
doing pranks backstage
you once had a guy with you who was
bleeding from the ear and we kept asking
him is he okay and you say oh don't
worry about him
we thought he was having some kind of
brain hemorrhage it turned out he's a
friend of yours and you guys were doing
a prank on
us none of it was recorded this had
nothing to do with your appearance on
the show
it was um it was just for your own
amusement so now
what's nice is you and your daughter are
saying let's capture some of that
and uh waste more people's time with it
i'm so sorry about that
you want an apology oh no no don't i
remember no
it was funny it was funny it was funny
from new york you came to do the show in
l.a yeah well it's funny now i don't
think jeff
i don't think my producer was really
worried that someone
this friend of yours was having a brain
aneurysm and he was trying to convince
that person
he was thinking about calling an emt we
got to get this guy a brain scan
and it was youtube ben affleck actually
picked him up from the floor so i
brought in
he was supposed to be by he was acting
he was my agent and my pr guy
i'm doing conan and he had uh he had
these blood
pellets that come out of his ears and
his nose and he was bleeding and he
would be
on the floor bleeding but asking the
segment producer you know is howie
mandel going on
first my client and they go well you're
bleeding shouldn't we call somebody
he goes it's not about me can i go over
this segment with you yeah they're going
no
sir sir you bleep you're bleeding you're
bleeding and then
it was fun for me just to sit back and
watch this chain of events that they
would go tell somebody
and you're you know five minutes away
from a huge broadcast
network show where you travel you're not
in your home studio like you don't have
enough
and i've got this idiot my friend idiot
lying on the floor blood spewing out
going
can we go over the segment one more time
yes you know i remember thinking
that guy's a great agent because
man you know that's everyone's dream is
an agent who would be bleeding from both
ears
and still be looking out for your
interests and not going to the hospital
that's the dream